bro
before they call you back man it's been
a crazy wednesday your mom told me you
got sprung out of jail but she won't say
where you at
you still fully right
i'm gonna lay that way
it's not capping y'all man this [ __ ]
happened so quick but rashad's got a bag
on your headphones
you're saying you switched to get out
what
ryan's national body
my uncle pulled some crazy lawyer [ __ ]
that's all i
i'm
know
once you dead bro
i think i'm next
you gotta come back and clear this [ __ ]
up like asap just be cool all right be
cool and lay low all right
i'm scared
coming
i'm gonna fix this
[Music]
tell me what's your father said odb what
no jazz man i gotta get to lex man i
gotta catch your midnight like to philly
wait you didn't kill a rob nobody in
that mansion did you cuz i ain't trying
to catch a case wheel oh man everybody
in the mansion is good i just gotta get
back home asap right come on let's go
but
who are you
phillip banks will's uncle who the hell
are you
uh
jazz
what up
jess
thank you for your time jess
thank you for your money phil
let's go back inside will
i guess you missed the 20 cameras
surrounding the property
by the way what was the plan here so you
go to lax and then what hmm
and then
fly home and fix my situation hmm
what about that gangster you pulled a
gun on
and i find it hard to believe he just
let that go
what was he planned there
let me ask you something will
you care if you live or die
me too
so it is your mom your aunt
and everyone in this house i can handle
mine
ain't never had no daddy
i've been my own man
a real man takes the time to consider
the consequences of his actions
a real man knows when to let go of his
pride and make the most out of a second
chance
a real man also knows how to look
another man in the eye when they're
saying something look at me
i believe in you will
be patient
give this a real chance and i promise
that you'll have every opportunity to
create the future you want
you have my word
do we have a deal
good
you